Typically, how long should I wait until I get another cheek swab test?
Well, it depends on if it's your so so typically what after your initial cheek swab test I
Typically recommend getting another one 30 60 or 90 days depending on how fast I think your protocol may change
and
How ill a person is we want to stay on top of things
You know more rapidly
So, but you know, I've had people where they do the initial cheek swab test and literally we it's like they've gone off the face of the earth
We haven't heard for them in two years
So I think as much as I don't want to create a
patient base that is
co-dependent on us I
Also don't want people to think that they can't communicate with us
So I think there's a balance between creating a co-dependent relationship and
Not utilizing the services that you paid for
So I feel sad what I haven't heard from people for a long long time in one sense
Because I miss them. I hope they're doing well. I don't even know if they're doing well. I
also understand that
Some people are doing great and they don't want to do anything else. They feel great
And they feel like they're going to handle on things and they got what they paid for I get that also
So I'm trying to understand that balance wherever a person is at and accept that
But typically I
Think you should get retested, you know after your initial cheek swab test within about 60 to 90 days
And then after that it depends on if things change so if your symptoms change if you're
Objective findings change meaning your tests are getting worse. You're feeling worse that you should do it again
If things are you're doing great and things are doing great and you're objective findings
And say you're still with an oncologist and your CT scan is coming back
No evidence of disease. I mean, I guess I would just stay in the course and stay doing what you're doing
so
You know, many times when we talked I think I spoke to a person recently haven't heard from for a couple years and he's doing great and
Okay, well, that's fantastic
But I also you want to encourage people to stay in communication with us
For our sake, too
So yeah, it depends on you know, I always said that you do another cheek swab kind of like if you you'd go to the doctor because something changed
Something was new or you're trying to
Objectify what is going on and making decisions on supplements and diet to things so you should stay atop of it
But I also know that person is doing really well. They may just stay the course as long as they're doing really well
So it's a balance there